I'm going to use today to actually cover some introductory material.
We will use most of the 50 minutes.
Uh,
the last part of today's lecture,
we'll describe the course,
it's requirements,
uh,
and so forth.
So let's begin capitalism.
We're going to break the subject today into three headings,
capital capitalism,
and of course three C's,
if you will.
The,
I've chosen an,
and I usually do this,
I've chosen a one segment of the economy as the theme for the day.
Uh,
and today that segment is revealed in this slide.
MMM.
Calhoun athletics.
Xxl,
can you interpret the slide?
Okay.
What,
what in particular?
Okay.
Uh,
how bout Varick bottled water.
Okay.
They are indeed crop circles,
a score one for Mbas.
Uh,
they are crop circles and all of us who travel,
uh,
from,
east to west across the country.
I have seen them,
but we haven't seen them quite in this density because this photograph is taken
from space.
It's a NASA image and it,
uh,
it's an extraordinarily elegant,
a display of something very simple.
Now,
why would center pivot agriculture interest us from the point of view of
capitalism?
The MS formatted slide here says capital.
Uh,
this is a definition that comes down to us through the Oxford English dictionary
from the early 17th century.
And uh,
let me read it in full and then we'll boil it down to more manageable terms.
Capitol is the art accumulated wealth of an individual company or community used
as a fun to carry on fresh production wealth in any form used to help in
producing more wealth.
And there's a shift between those two meanings.
The first is a very broad understanding of capital.
The second is very close to the way you would have to think about capital in
connection with an economic system called Capitol Ism.
Okay,
so let's start with the broader usage.
A Capitol is accumulated wealth used as a fund in carrying on production.
Uh,
it's a very broad idea.
It is one which arguably in fact,
I think without much argument,
uh,
it goes back 10,000 years to the establishment of agricultural society and very
possibly another hundred,
hundred and 20,000 years to organized hunter gatherers using weapons and tools.
Does this qualify?
Okay.
Is that not capital?
What do you think should I could for purple.
Okay.
It is capital.
All right.
Excuse me.
Can you handle this?
Oh,
I think have a use of capital because it's sort of kind of like accumulate
wealth and you kind of use nuts from pain.
No.
For,
for art to do it at,
well
does this meet the next step?
You need the mic a little closer.
Well,
it doesn't really have any fresh productions.
Okay.
So what,
what does this role that?
Nothing in material.
Good.
It's pretty much the squirrel.
Okay.
Hand the mic to somebody else and we'll this,
it's the hot potato
or just pass it around and wherever it is,
when I ask a question that's your turn.
Yeah,
that'll be good.
Uh,
the nest is producing Nass blanks.
Um,
and it's a little closer to what we mean
beaver dam producing a working environment for beavers to carry out their
business closer infrastructure,
if you will.
The honeycomb that bees years.
Uh,
this one is actually the one that is close to intuitively to capital,
right?
The accumulated wealth is the energy and silk required to weave the nest or
weave the web.
And the web is indeed an instrument,
uh,
for the work of capturing prey,
but there's no external product beyond them.
So even that is not quite what we have in mind.
Now.
How about sheet the seeds used in agriculture?
Where's the job?
Okay.
So you recognize that seems like this constitute capital holding like really
close.
I don't really think so.
Okay.
Well,
I guess that a seed produces a plant,
but um,
it doesn't really,
well I guess,
yeah,
maybe the seed producing the plant and then the plant produces more seeds in it
sort of keeps generating more and more seeds.
Is that capital?
Um,
I mean like it to me.
Well,
you know,
I guess the capital sort of,
uh,
um,
and never ending way of accumulating more wealth.
Um,
I think so.
Yeah.
Capitalists fail,
but good capitalists don't.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
kilograms of sheep.
would anybody
say that there's,
that it isn't enough to count was capital
is if,
if is one seat,
does that make it capital
it I said what kind of seed is it
for throwing safflower
explicit information for me.
You got to get you something back.
I think seeds in any quantity can be capital because each,
once you planted,
and if there is a like,
you know,
successful pollination and everything like that before,
um,
you can always use the plants to produce more seed.
In fact,
that's what a lot of farms do and that's what a lot of farms get in trouble for
because other companies want to control those seeds.
Pat Patent
violation issue.
If I use hybrid seed to generate more hybrid sheet,
there may be,
there's an argument there.
Okay,
so quantity doesn't matter at all.
Yes.
I would say quantity matters if you're a subsistence farmer because if you just
have enough seed to feed yourself,
that's not capital,
that's just keeping you alive.
You aren't producing any further well from it.
And if I gave you this much,
uh,
well,
if I'm not a farmer,
if I have some other means of supporting myself,
that could be capital for upside business,
but that wouldn't
be for subsistence farmer.
I think it's really worth having the business over 26.
Well,
no,
I don't think so.
And what I'm driving at here is the notion of minimum efficient scale capital
gets a resource,
gets to be capital only when it's aggregated to a scale where it can be fic
effectively enough deployed to compete in an actual economy.
Now what's your take
too big a note?
Let's take a dollar.
MMM.
Have I just given you a capital or not?
Yeah,
technically yes.
But probably that wouldn't allow me to,
uh,
set up a budding business over here.
How am I going to become a piece of cabinets?
Well,
if somebody else gives me a dollar or more,
$3 is enough for you.
No,
but,
um,
if,
if I have more investors and they will be giving more than a dollar.
Okay.
So your need some aggregation or collaboration.
And how does,
how does she,
how do we aggregate capital in an actual economy?
IPOS are a big way to,
yeah,
do what the end in general,
the joint stock corporation is a way to do it.
How do banks aggregate capital
rolling
deposits.
Okay.
Thousands of little deposits make big funds.
So we're getting there with capital.
And what I want to do now is continue the agricultural theme.
Uh,
see if we can relate what we're talking about to the generation of actual wealth
in society.
Okay.
Uh,
this is called a seed drill
and it is a way of planning millions of seeds in a very systematic,
precise,
and cost effective way.
And one characteristic feature of how capital works is combining different
factors in the production of the same thing in an extremely intelligent way,
a way that represents the accumulated experience,
uh,
of society.
And when you do it well,
uh,
you succeed.
And when you do it poorly,
you fail.
You can actually fail even when you do it well,
but you're very unlikely to succeed when you do it poorly.
Now here I want to compare two,
uh,
two very similar technologies.
This is a peasant farming in Tibet.
Uh,
and the motive power here is a pair of yaks
and this was a John Deere tractor.
And the spectacular difference between these two things,
it's obvious to us all it is that one of them is,
constitutes a large investment of capital.
Uh,
in the case of that tractor and the gear where the well over $100,000 must be
invested,
uh,
the yaks,
well,
I dunno what JAKKS cost in Tibet,
but less.
And we would say that the John Deere photograph represents something that's
capital intensive.
And the Yak photograph represents something which is,
excuse me,
labor intensive,
and we would expect a much higher return in pro and in food food generated per
hour of labor invested fromm the highly mechanized capital intensive story.
And the history of the world in the last thousand years is essentially the
history of substitution for,
of the right hand picture for the lefthand of capital intensive,
highly mechanized means of production in the place of labor intensive low
capitalization,
uh,
means of production.
Yeah.
Another comparison,
excuse me.
Uh,
the capital intensivity here,
the ratio of that watering cans,
capital cost to the center pivot that might be as much as 500 meters long would
be measured in the thousands to one,
the tens of thousands,
the hundreds of thousands,
probably enormous difference in the level of investment.
Also those of you were interested in the environment and all of us should be a,
there is a huge difference in environmental impact.
The labor intensive agriculture essentially leaves the environment unchanged
whereas this kind of agriculture practiced in a,
it's now a world center pivot.
Irrigation is a worldwide technology and in many places it draws so much water
so fast and so much water is lost to evaporation that the underlying aquifer is
rapidly being depleted.
I here are two center pivot photographs and they to differ in capitalization.
The one on the left is from Egypt.
Uh,
the one on the right is from Iowa and the difference between them in the cost of
the land would be dramatic.
The market price of highly productive loam soil in one of the three or four
richest agricultural zones in the world is much higher than in,
uh,
the margin of the world's largest desert.
Uh,
here's another,
I kind of get carried away with center pivot agriculture.
Uh,
here's another slide of the same kind from the same source.
And this is in southern France who's been to southern France.
Pretty Great,
isn't it?
I have many reservations about French politics,
uh,
but southern France is one of the nicest places I've ever been.
And I,
this summer we'll meet a guy here in a month,
a named Paulos Arnone,
uh,
who is a robber baron,
a Goldman Sachs partner,
and he just built a villa overlooking can in southern France and I had to be
taken away by security.
Um,
what's striking about this photograph in comparison with the others?
What's the,
what's the dramatic difference between this one and the Egyptian one and the
Iowa one
purple.
That's not what I'm fishing for guys.
Yeah.
Okay.
You got to talk really,
where do I have the mic?
Here it is.
Please pass this over again.
Push the on button and it'll be on.
Yeah,
I,
there's other things in the middle of the like the green and purple circles.
Okay.
And what are the other things?
Yeah.
I can't tell if that's houses are well,
why are all these little polygons look at the right margin for example,
right.
They are take your gas,
they're not soccer fields,
right?
Who wants to take a guess at fish?
Yes.
Pasture.
Okay.
They might be pasture.
What they really,
what they are more generally you have the,
uh,
we'll get better at this microphone thing as we go.
Um,
what they are is very small farms.
There are farms where the meets and bounds pat trace back perhaps 800,
1,012 hundred years.
And they were farms which worked economically when the world was less developed
in capital intensive agriculture,
but they have been rendered marginal by the transformation of world agriculture.
Now the question for you,
you ready for a policy question?
Okay.
Your name is now Sarcozi
and the question is,
should we increase,
let's suppose that 20% of these farms are failing a year and we're already
subsidizing them pretty heavily.
Should we subsidize them more so that the rate at which they closed down is
diminished?
Mr Sarcozi must you,
I would say if you really want to effectively decrease the rate at which they're
failing,
you'd want to encourage consolidation.
It looks like the problem here is a real fragmentation.
Okay.
The problem is fragmentation.
That's a really good start.
Now,
uh,
the person,
immediately to your right
is your political consultant
and she's going to tell you whether what you just said is going to wash in Leo
or not.
How's that the Sarcozi consolidation program.
How's that going to play?
Repeat the question please.
Okay.
Sarcozi you just said
these little fragments of land art in the street and we get efficient way to do
agriculture and he,
she was right on that point.
And it goes on to say that we should try and capture the stable economies
Bayfield by consolidating.
And you're talking now you are a public official.
Uh,
what,
how's that going to read for you statement
that we should announce the Sarcozi agricultural consolidation.
Wow.
I don't think the public would like it.
Like the small fibers solars would hate it.
And it was slow cars play a special role in the life of the imagination of,
okay,
so probably won't happen.
And France,
this is,
this is a characteristic fact about all the capitalist democracies is that
pressure groups play an enormously important role in actual policy.
And the one book which is available for purchase at labyrinth but which isn't
actually required a is Christopher Buckley's.
Thank you for smoking.
How many of you have read this book?
Pardon?
Oh,
the movie.
How many of you've seen the movie?
Uh,
it's all about the biases of pressure groups and public relations in the
capitalist in the largest capitalist democracy,
which is our own,
I just couldn't resist throwing this one.
And this is the Libyan desert
and uh,
center pivot agriculture plus maybe something else that,
uh,
uncles,
observers from the sky I found interesting.
Yeah.
Okay.
So a general theme here,
a strategy,
be a strategy,
a is labor intensive.
Production Strategy B is capital intensive production.
The
single biggest story,
I'm repeating myself here because it's such a big point,
uh,
in recent world history is the substitution of strategy be for strategy a and
that happening on an extremely uneven basis.
It's happening in a big way and fast some places and in a little way and slow
other places and that generates an enormous vertical dimension to the world.
So there are income ratios between households measured in the millions,
millions to one.
Uh,
and that provides,
uh,
some of the interest,
in the functioning of capitalism,
which brings us to the subject
now,
uh,
comparing,
labor intensive,
the Red Arrow with capital intensive,
the Blue Arrow,
we have here a very simple production function where labor expended is on the
horizontal axis and units produced is on the vertical.
Oh,
for those of you who are actually taking this course,
these slides,
I posted them just before class.
And so if you,
I mean,
you can just,
you don't have to write this stuff down.
Uh,
and if you project
differences in rates of return over long periods,
here I've put a hundred production cycles and one curve is increasing at 1%.
The red one,
the other is increasing at 4% per cycle and by the end of the period there is a
monstrous difference in the rate at which they are accumulating and in actual,
okay.
In actual fact,
very small differences,
I've greatly overstated them in the production function here,
the difference between 4% and 3% or between 2.5% and 1%,
uh,
are enormously consequential when projected over time and at a given moment in
time are enormously consequential from a competitive point of view.
Because if you are not the low cost producer,
uh,
the low cost producer is in a position where if she has sufficient scale of
operation,
she can drive you out of business.
Yeah,
no,
everything we've said so far,
uh,
could be true of almost any economic system.
Uh,
I put the grass here to suggest Tang China.
This was one of the great periods in Chinese cultural and economic history,
uh,
ending more than a thousand years ago.
And the,
the use of capital,
not necessarily in the highly intensive form,
but the use of capital in this economic cycle we were talking about,
uh,
it was a perfectly normal practice,
which the Tang dynasty would have understood easily.
And they were,
by the way,
just as inventive as we have been in the last couple of hundred years.
What they didn't have was the ability to go to scale.
Yeah.
Or it could have been in as [inaudible] as suggested in this Broyle painting.
Uh,
we could be thinking of Europe in the 15th century or the 16th Century,
uh,
before the capitalist revolution because there was always the reliance on
capitol,
lower levels of intent in intensivity because there was less capital in total.
And it could even have been,
we could even be talking about an agricultural cooperative in the Soviet Union,
which,
uh,
used,
capital,
uh,
in the form of tractors and land and seed and so on,
but used it in a very different way than it is used in market economies
to capitalism.
Okay.
Oh,
let's switch now to the lower,
the lower usage here.
The acute,
the,
it is the use of accumulated wealth to produce more wealth.
Mark's makes a big point of this wealth commodity wealth WOC w and sees this as,
um,
as
pathological
as a distortion of human values.
And we'll talk through Mark's,
uh,
in,
about a week or 10 days.
Uh,
the great man,
how many of you have read as many as 10 pages of Marx's writing?
Okay.
Where do we read Mark's at Yale these days?
Yeah.
Philosophy department.
Where else?
Directed Studies and what is directed studies.
Read Marx.
Communist manifesto.
That's great.
You're well prepared for this class because we're going to read it next week.
MMM.
What would you say of marks as a writer?
First of all,
he wrote in German,
but
who's got an editorial opinion about Marx's riding?
Yes.
You got to shout without the mic.
Very talented,
very talented writer.
Uh,
I agree.
A very smart guy.
MMM.
If you were marking up marking of Mark's term paper up,
what would you find fault with
very windy and a little overwrought,
right?
I mean,
he really wants to hit you in the face five times with each thought.
Um,
but what we'll discover is interesting is that Mark's,
Mark's,
uh,
in the manifesto and Engels look at capitalism in a way,
very similar to the way we look at it today.
And they did,
they emphasize itch,
enormous productive capacity.
And they also emphasize that it is always on the edge of being out of control.
Yeah.
Capitalism as a word comes into the English language in the middle of the 18
hundreds.
And it comes in because of Mark's and people like Marx,
uh,
it is a pejorative use to attack the existing economic system.
Capitalism is seen not as a highly productive system,
but as an unjust system.
Uh,
and,
and it's criticized in other ways,
which I'll tick off in a moment.
Anybody recognize this fellow?
Yes,
it's JP Morgan.
And,
uh,
does anybody know who took this photograph?
That's a little hard.
Steichen and it's a very famous photograph.
What's famous about it?
What does,
what,
what's striking about this image?
Great.
Does he look friendly,
warm and fuzzy?
No.
And he wasn't,
I mean,
this,
this was a very hard edge guy.
Uh,
and what seems to be in his left hand,
it is a chair.
It is the arm of a chair.
Uh,
but the reflection,
uh,
makes it look like he's holding a dagger.
And it was no accident.
Uh,
[inaudible] was not a fan.
Um,
and this has been used.
Photographs been used thousands of times in a polemical way.
Okay.
Capitalism as seen in the 19th century,
a disease for which site?
Scientific Socialism,
that's Marx's term for Marx,
uh,
is the cure.
Of course,
there were 20 or 30 other brands of socialism that Mark's regarded as
unscientific.
Uh,
it is a method by which to steal the Labor of labor from the exploited masters.
And the reasoning which we'll review in 10 days time is that capital can never
make money except by using either labor now or the accumulated fruit of labor
from the past.
And if capital ends up with a profit,
that profit must be extracted from either living or fossilized labor.
Uh,
this is not a thought which I share.
It is a system which undermines traditional society in all its forms and
undermines traditional skill sets.
And that's a perfectly true statement.
And when it happens,
it is very coercive.
It is indeed a trademark of the way capitalism works.
That a skillset which was a competitive and AU courant in 1980,
uh,
may not command,
as much as the minimum wage in 2009.
And this is the kicker for Marx is the claim that capitalism inevitably will
destroy itself.
It will undermine its own foundations and ultimately disappeared.
Uh,
we will evaluate that
view.
Oh,
am I,
this slide is cut off all the cut off the main part of the,
of what's here.
So I'll have to remember it for you.
A capitalism is the name given to an economic system by its enemies.
So 0.1 by its enemies point to a system which relies heavily on the private use
of capital,
heavily on the private use of capital combined with uh,
the profit motive founded on self interest or family interest
so that there are hundreds of variations on the capitalist system,
but the essentials are private deployment of capital,
uh,
open acknowledgement of profit as a motive and,
a sympathetic understanding of cell for household interest.
Yeah.
Another frequent part of the package is a tolerance for innovation.
And one of the characteristic facts about historical society is a resistance to
innovation.
And the temptation to resist change is always there.
It is absolutely always there.
And as people grow older,
they grow more set in their ways and expect expectations and less tolerant of
fresh innovation.
Okay,
this course.
Okay.
Uh,
we're going to start with some excerpts from the wealth of nations.
It is available on classes vitu posted under resources.
How many of you have read at least at least a chapter of wealth of nations.
Okay.
The of you are in for a treat.
Uh,
Smith is not only a great writer,
but a great thinker.
A He is a much more complex thinker than we usually imagine him to be.
He was not a believer that it's just fine for the port of starve in the screech.
Yet actually very complicated views about that which are broadly analogous to a
philosopher,
John Rawls and Rawls has difference principle about what inequalities are
justified,
namely those which redound ultimately in some way to the benefit of the least
favored a Sh,
a straight up in an economy.
Uh,
the manifesto already mentioned.
Um,
and in both cases we'll,
um,
we'll leave be valid.
Good bit.
A Smith is a very long book.
I recommend to you the Bantam Paperback,
$7 and 95 cents of Smith because it has wonderful little,
um,
summaries of each paragraph in Italics,
uh,
which allows speed reading,
which is actually a very useful thing when a book would take a week to plow
through in a careful,
careful reading.
And we'll focus on just three or four points there,
three or four arguments and Smith.
But they are a really powerful and important arguments.
Uh,
the Constitution of liberty is by FAA Hayak and we'll just read two chapters.
There'll be in a packet which you'll get.
Um,
and high tech is the arch conservative,
the market conservative,
uh,
from whom most of the conservative movement,
not concerned with social authority,
but the libertarian side of American conservatism relies primarily on high tech,
actually
a farewell to alms.
Um,
this book,
uh,
by a guy named Gregory Clark is a book which says capitalism more and better
pour it on.
And as capitalism is in increases its reach,
the world will grow wealthier and better.
It is a polemical work written by an economist,
uh,
and you'll find things to argue with even if you more or less agree with him,
you'll find many things to argue with him about.
And that will be an important book in the course.
Uh,
the mystery of capital,
uh,
by Hernando de Soto is an argument about why the less developed in the world are
less developed.
And the gist of it is that formal and enforceable property rights are a
precondition to capital development and it's a,
it's a very powerful piece of work.
Richard Posner,
a failure of capitalism,
a Posner,
anybody new who Posner is.
Yeah.
Tell us loud and clear.
He's a judge and he's a judge of what persuasion would you say?
He's a very conservative judge,
uh,
teaches at the University of Chicago Law School and he has written a very
penetrating analysis of the current crisis.
Uh,
it is,
I read maybe 20 books to pick one on this subject and uh,
this is the clearest and most honest I think.
And he doesn't,
he does no ideological distortion here that I can detect.
It is just a penetrating and straightforward analysis of what happened.
And um,
for that reason very useful.
Uh,
the bottom billion
by Paul Collier who is a World Bank economist who teaches at Oxford and,
uh,
in this maps out a diagnosis and a strategy for using market mechanisms and
capital capital development to alleviate most of the world's poverty.
Finally,
the white tiger.
This is fiction,
but there are times when fiction is better at describing the real world than
nonfiction.
And this is a brutally a penetrating novels,
uh,
written from the point of view of a very poor,
very smart,
uh,
and in many ways flawed young man in south India.
It won the man Booker Prize last year for uh,
fiction.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
for our age,
it is as good as dickens and Zola,
uh,
were for the 19th century.
It's a just a brilliant book.
I couldn't put it down.
Um,
and I tend,
people told me I had to read it and I kept shrugging my shoulders.
Then when I started,
I read it front to back,
uh,
in one long day.
And it is if you want to understand why there are a billion or 2 billion people
out there for whom capitalism looks not like,
uh,
a powerful mechanism of production,
but like extremely coercive system,
uh,
the white tiger is a great way to do that.
Uh,
and Chris Buckley's thank you for smoking is optional.
we will also use the case method and the case method occupies,
occupies about a third of the course and we will use the ones in in white are
straightforward cases,
the ones in gold,
we'll have the people in the room or some of the people.
Um,
Polaroid is the story of,
uh,
the land camera and a brilliant technology which ultimately crashed and burned.
And it's the case is a Harvard business school case about the attempt to get
that business,
uh,
through its crisis at the time that it went broke.
Goldman Sachs Ipo a terrifically it's a,
it's a good HBS case and better yet we'll have paolos and only with us,
uh,
to tell the story from the inside of the Goldman Goldman system.
Uh,
wanting to wrap a chin ski is a story of,
uh,
getting a business going in Poland just after the death of communism,
a Yale trained business woman who,
um,
created something called [inaudible],
which is the largest publishing company in East Europe and how she coped with
the toxic environment,
that toxic business environment,
a leftover by communism.
Um,
Selco India is a micro finance story.
cardiothoracic systems is a tech story and I'm going to have the dean of som
come and do it as a business case with you,
which means you're going to need to wear helmets.
She is an aggressive cold call and oh,
by the way,
I'm going to make two kinds of calls in this course,
cold calls or the kind of thing I did today where that where you get no warning,
uh,
and warm calls.
I'll send you an email and say heads up about,
and um,
in the second case you really ought to have something to say.
Um,
and uh,
they'll,
they're there.
There's some of the fun in this stuff is the back and forth between you and me
and you and you,
um,
the Enron case,
uh,
Jim Alexander is an important guy in this course.
Jim,
would you just stand up and wave?
Uh,
Jim was,
Jim is a good friend of mine,
um,
who had a career in investment banking,
uh,
and then at Enron and he was chief financial officer of Enron global pipeline
and power.
And he saw what was happening and got out.
Um,
he is referred to as the fly in the ointment in smartest guys in the room,
which is,
uh,
the popularized story of Enron's crash.
Uh,
he then went on and,
uh,
cofounded spinnaker exploration,
who's operating principle was,
think what Enron would do and do the other.
And,
uh,
spinnaker,
became a public company,
uh,
and was extremely successful.
A medley global advisors.
This is a case about gathering business intelligence and selling it for large
price.
High prices,
excuse my voice.
A medley is another Yale trained person.
Uh,
he founded the company and the case is about his attempt to sell the company,
which he did.
So he's selling a company that for which is eponymously his and,
uh,
walking away,
he actually sold it for 57 million bucks,
and it's a no mentally medleys story and it's,
he's a very interesting guy.
Uh,
and then maybe we'll talk about Maurice.
I am chair of the workout committee,
which is trying to put more,
he's back in business and it turns out to be a really interesting hard task.